[موسيقى]
أنا آنا إيفانوفنا ديميدوفا ، ولدت في 20
نوفمبر 1925 في قرية مويسيف
منطقة فيتيبسك في بيلاروسيا
عندما سمعنا أن الحرب قد بدأت
قررت أن شيئًا ما يجب القيام به بينما أنا
غادر على الفور تحت polycom للأفكار
عمال كومسومول السوفيت
عامل صغير تحت الأرض كان لدينا مدير
مدرستنا
ذهب القائد للاتصال بنا في المدرسة و
قال الرجال دعونا
امينات استطلاع الجبهة على ديفيد
مياه بحيرة كانسو الشعاب البيلاروسية الأصعدة
المنزل أو اللعنة المحيط النشوة أعشقها
لكسر البلوط واندفع ، لكنه خرج
مثل جوليا جيتس في صباح جبا
كان الموت مهما بالنسبة لك
بالطبع ، كان أفظع شيء هو الموت و
علاوة على ذلك ، كانت الإصابة مخيفة أيضًا ، ولا داعي لها
سوف يهرب بطريقة ما من هذا الوضع
كان من المخيف مشاهدته
الناس الأحياء يحترقون في المنزل ، من تفهم
قريبي السبعة عشر في القضية أنا
اعتقدت دائمًا أنه جيدًا ، يمكنك أن تخلص
وأعتقد أن الرجل السمين سيفوز ، أعتقد ذلك
دولته كبيرة بلدنا فواتيري 8 أ
لا يزال هناك كم أنت من أورالسيب ، رغم ذلك
مرة أخرى أوه ، محو ذنب سيو لتوم أناكين
على قناة ايليا
sabaton your rune million hotel agadir
اضغط على خيمة أربو على الدواسة و
المسيطر الحيوي
خردة على القبعة أنا التراخي و u no ko phi
لطخ فلاديفوستوك يفيم غولدبرغ أنا فيه
كورو
حامل الحلوى 2
حدث ذلك في 15 مارس من هذا العام
عمري مائة وخمس سنوات
خائفة ليس فقط في أيام نادرة بسبب
أنها لمست أي بلدة
خسارة الرقيق ونحن ديوتا
الذي لم يتم استعادته في أي شخص
سؤال
تكمن في أي نزاع ولكن فقط بدون حرب
ويشمل الحرب ولا يشمل هذا الشرطي العصبي
ولد الإنسان ليعيش مثل الطيور
رحلة طيران
البيرة وطن من سقي المافيا في المقصورة
نوافذ الدوري وتحارب القائمة البريدية أو بولينا ط
وصلت فلادا تنسي الأعمام
تفاصيل حديقة الأدوار تأخذ الأم ويارا أو
على رجل باتو هوي على ارتفاع
الساحة لنا من معرف وهي سوري
ألبا من خلال تخصيص جولة مكسيم هي
أنهم
فلاديفوستوك
الموجات فوق الصوتية